and economic support to some of our
neighbors under economic stress
today specific
Council today
let me emphasize that even in Conflict
situations
there can be no justification for
violation of Human Rights or of
international law
where any such acts occur it is
imperative that they are investigated in
an objective and independent manner
this was the position we took with
regard to the killings in bucha and this
is the position we take even today
the council will also recall that we had
then supported calls for an independent
investigation into the butcher incident
the fight against impunity is critical
to the larger pursuit of securing peace
and justice
the security Council must send an
unambiguous and unequivocal message on
this court
politics should never ever
provide cover to evade accountability
nor indeed to facilitate impunity
regrettably we have seen this of late in
this very chamber when it comes to
sanctioning of some of the world's most
dreaded terrorists
if egregious attacks committed in broad
daylight are left unpunished this
Council must reflect on the signals we
are sending on impunity
there must be consistency if we are to
ensure credibility
once again let me emphasize Madam
president
that the need of the r is to end this
conflict in Ukraine and return to the
negotiating table
this council is the most powerful
contemporary symbol of diplomacy
it must continue to live up to its
purpose
the global order that we all subscribe
to is based on international law U.N
Charter and respect for the territorial
integrity and sovereignty of all states
these principles too must be upheld
without exception I thank you madam
president
s
again
[Music]
[Music]
the ruins of devastation
[Music]
and the conference which foreign
authors of atrocities
must respect International conventions
and solidarity which is all to deserve
reserved for the war in Ukraine
fatal many Africans including young
students
shame and humiliation
many will refuse the assistance in you
just as much as those sharing with us
suffering team fear and distress
rise together to strongly denounce it so
the double Center is no longer the rule
and so many times
and foreign
[Music]
on parties to negotiate the respect for
Humanity in law the practices the
principles of the Indian Charter
Schools
Mr foreign
foreign
their mother tongue
non-humans
sometimes there are species
connections
foreign
authorities
and of course
foreign
foreign
using
um
[Music]
and the Russians foreign
foreign
civilians upstairs
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
Museum
foreign
foreign
thank you very much
of the United Kingdom of Great Britain
Northern Ireland uh Madam president Mr
secretary Mr Secretary General Mr Khan
thank you
UN members agreed solemn principles in
the UN Charter vital for International
Peace and security
they undertook to refrain from the
threat or the use of force against the
territorial integrity
or the political independence of any
state
yet seven months ago President Putin
invaded Ukraine illegally
and without justification
he ignored the resounding pleas for
peace that I heard in this Council on
the 17th of February
since then Ukrainian Spirit of defense
and Defiance in the protection of their
country continues to inspire free
peoples
and Nations
every day
devastating consequences of Russia's
Invasion become more clear
un agencies have confirmed more than 14
000 civilian casualties so far
and the actual total is likely to be
much higher more than 17 million
ukrainians in humanitarian need 7
million displaced within Ukraine and
more than 7 million Ukrainian refugees
in Europe
we see the mounting evidence of Russian
atrocities against civilians including
indiscriminate shelling and targeted
attacks on over 200 medical facilities
and 40 educational institutions and
horrific acts of sexual violence
we see from the reports of the office of
the High Commissioner for human rights
that in parts of Ukraine currently under
Russian control civilians are subject to
torture
arbitrary detention and forced
deportation to Russia
and we have seen more grisly discoveries
in ism
it's not just ukrainians who are the
victims
President Putin's War has spread
hardship and food insecurity across the
globe plunging millions of the world's
most vulnerable
into hunger
and famine
and once again as we've seen here today
Russia has sought to deny responsibility
it has tried to lay the blame on those
who have rightly imposed sanctions on
President Putin's regime in response to
his illegal actions
us be clear we are not sanctioning food
it is Russia's actions that are
preventing food and fertilizer getting
to developing countries it is Russia's
tactics and bombs that are to blame for
destroying Ukraine's Farms
infrastructure and delaying its exports
I sat here in February
listening to the Russian representative
assuring this Council
that Russia had no intention of invading
its neighbor
we now know that was a lie
and today I have listened to further
installments of Russia's catalogs of
distortions
dishonesty and disinformation
he has left the chamber
I'm not surprised I don't think Mr
lavrov wants to hear
the collective condemnation of this
Council but we saw through him then and
we saw through him again today
we have information
which means that we know
that Russia is about to hold sham
referenda on Sovereign Ukrainian
territory
with no basis in law
under the threat of violence after mass
displacements of people in areas that
voted overwhelmingly
for Ukrainian Independence
we know
what Vladimir Putin is doing
he is planning to fabricate the outcome
of those referenda
he is planning to use that to Annex
Sovereign Ukrainian territory
and he is planning to use it as a
further pretext
to escalate his aggression that is what
he plans to do
and we call on all countries
to reject the charade
and to refuse to recognize any results
we are used to seeing Russian lies and
distortions
but
let us listen to the testimony of
ukrainians who tell us the truth
who tell us the reality
on President Putin's War
Dr Elena usvak
her husband
Ole
and their 22 year old son dimitro
were abducted by Russian forces from
their home in Hostel
near Buca in March
Russian soldiers shot Olay twice in the
legs
before they were all blindfolded and
bundled into an armored personnel
carrier and I want you to hear only a
story in her own words and I quote
first they took us to a bombed out house
the Russian soldiers kept saying they
were going to kill us my husband was
left for hours lying on the floor in the
pool of his blood
I don't know why
we'd done nothing wrong
then they took my son away from us I
don't know where I don't know if we'll
ever see him again I just want my boy
back
end of quote
Elena's story
and those are many others tell us the
truth the real truth this is a war of
annexation a war of Conquest to which
President Putin now wants to send even
more of Russia's young men and women
making peace even less like less likely
Mr Putin must understand the world is
watching and we will not give up
members of the security Council we must
unequivocally reject Russia's attempts
to Annex Ukrainian territory we must
make clear to President Putin that his
attack on the Ukrainian people must stop
that there can be no impunity for those
perpetrating atrocities
and that he must withdraw from Ukraine
and restore Regional and global
stability
if he chose to he could stop this war
a war which was done Untold damage to
the Ukrainian and the Russian peoples
his war is an assault on Ukraine
an assault on the U.N Charter and an
assault on the international Norms that
protect us all so
we stand with our Ukrainian friends for
as long as it takes
because Ukraine's Fight For Freedom is
the world's Fight For Freedom it is our
fight for freedom and if Ukraine's
sovereignty
and territory are not respected
then no country is truly secure these
are the reasons why Ukraine can and must
win thank you
foreign
minister for foreign affairs and
Regional integration
excellencies
let me thank France for organizing this
high level meeting
I would also like to thank Secretary
General Antonio guterres for setting
that tone for this meeting with his very
clear statement we welcome also the
briefing from Mr Karim Khan the
prosecutor of the ICC
the world has been United since this
council's referral over Darfur in
resolution
1593 2005 nearly two decades ago that
impunity anywhere poses serious threats
to International Peace and security the
international legal order and our
multilateral system
we have systematically reinforced our
institutions and defined conduct and
sanctions to expose prevent or punish
those Acts or behaviors that defy the
Norms we are committed to live by
no State however powerful should get a
pass
to do so unravels a central tenet of our
Global civilization
it puts a stake the lives and Liberties
of those less powerful wherever they
live
that is why the members of this Council
must act in an urgent and unified manner
to end the near paralysis of the council
and the war in Ukraine
the toll of that war is intolerable and
the lack of unified resolve risks making
a universal organization an enabling
factor for impunity in Ukraine the
damage to the standing of the charter
may be incalculable
Ghana is especially concerned about the
intensification of the war in Ukraine
across several lines with civilian
populated areas and civilian
infrastructure being the targets of
bombardments we regret that the basic
laws which govern the conduct of modern
warfare and protect ordinary people who
are caught in the crossfires of War have
not been respected
we are distressed by the diverse
horrifying and painful humanitarian
threats which have accompanied the war
some 14 million people mostly women and
children have been displaced from their
homes and face heightened risk of
conflict-related sexual and gender-based
violence
human trafficking filtration processes
and false disappearances torture and
other violations of the rights and
freedoms of the people are widespread
we remain Gravely concerned by the
Manifest threats of a nuclear episode
whether by accident or deliberate action
because of the constant military
engagements around this zapore
nuclear nuclear power plants
that disregard for the requisites for
nuclear Safety and Security including
for the delineation of a safe zone are
deplorable and we support the efforts by
the international atomic energy agency
to avert a nuclear catastrophe
with a rising death toll civilian
casualties and growing reports of war
crimes and other human rights violations
we must uphold our responsibility as a
council and send a clear message that
perpetrators of atrocities would be held
to account the suffering in Ukraine is
abhorrent and should not be dismissed as
the mere consequence of War
to do so we would be endorsing the
atrocities and sanctioning impunity in
this regard
we underscore the importance of ensuring
accountability for all war crimes
committed in Ukraine
accountability is fundamental to
preventing impunity
we must affirm our determination that
the Litany of atrocious acts that have
taken place in Ukraine would be
submitted to thorough transparent and
independent investigations to establish
the facts and for the attribution of
international crimes to their
perpetrators
Ghana remains supportive of
international accountability measures
including the various investigative
processes being undertaken by the ICC
and the Human Rights Council
we believe that in seeking criminal
accountability and justice for the
victims of the war in Ukraine the
important questions about International
remedy and reparation measures
especially for victims of
conflict-related sexual abuses must be
addressed
we also express our support for the
United Nations early recovery and
resilience programs already been
undertaken Madame President we have we
have expressed several times a
principled position against the
aggression on Ukraine which we consider
to be a disregard for the rules of
international law and the principles of
the charter Ukraine as a sovereign state
and a member of this organization has
every right we believe and indeed a
responsibility to defend its territorial
integrity and political Independence we
recognize the tremendous courage and
resilience of the Ukrainian people
Ghana does not and will not recognize
any territory that is unilaterally and
forcefully required or acquired as
dismembered from a sovereign entity
we reiterate the call on the Russian
Federation to immediately and
unconditionally seize its oppressions we
draw its troops from the internationally
recognized borders of Ukraine and
respect its neighbor's sovereignty and
political Independence
the need for a credible pathway for a
genuine diplomatic process is urgent the
barrel of the gun does not provide such
a pathway it only leads to needless loss
of lives and distraction on both sides
indeed the cost of the war have been
high not only for the parties but also
for the rest of the world
as the president of Ghana said yesterday
in his statement at the general assembly
I quote
every bullet
every bump
every shell that hits a Target in
Ukraine hits our pockets and our
economies in Africa unquote
in this regard let me place on record
Ghana's appreciation for the good
offices of the Secretary General and
other International actors to leverage
life-saving humanitarian interventions
at critical times of the war we already
note some positive impacts from the
Black Sea grain initiative an edge that
continuous and unrestricted shipment of
grains to countries facing food
insecurity
we encourage all stakeholders to reach
an early agreement for the export of
Russian fertilizers and crop products
especially needed for agrarian dependent
economies Madam president let me
conclude with an appeal in a week when
the eyes of the world are on us and
millions around the world look to the
United Nations for leadership and hope
we must send a strong message that
impunity will not be tolerated that we
need to act through concerted diplomacy
to end the war in Ukraine I thank you
foreign
regions
far from where hostilities are taking
place
the Security Council is the appropriate
Forum to seek a solution that ensures
less than peace
this week marks seven months since the
start of the conflict
tens of thousands of people many of them
innocent civilians lost their lives
there are millions of refugees and
internally displaced persons whose
return to their homes remains uncertain
and who with the approach of fuenta are
faced with the prospect of a worsening
the humanitarian crisis
over these seven months this Council has
received numerous reports of serious
human rights violations in the conflict
Zone including against vulnerable groups
women and children
Brazil condemns the abuses and defends
an impartial investigation of the facts
so that those responsible are held
accountable for their actions
we also reiterate our call for full
respect for international humanitarian
law by all parties
Madame the president we have an
urgent task before us
to engage the parties in dialogue in
order to secure and immediate ceasefire
and the opening of negotiations for a
peace agreement
the continuation of the hostilities
endangers the lives of innocent
civilians and geopardizes the food and
energy security of millions of families
in other regions especially in
developing countries
the risks of escalation arising for the
current dynamics of the conflict are
simply too great and its consequences
for the world order unpredictable
only diplomacy brings the prospect of
viable solutions to conflicts between
states
it is not the time to accentuate
divisions or isolate parties
the priority of this Council must be to
create conditions for the parties to
engage in negotiations for a peaceful
solution to the conflict thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
on civilians
foreign
experience
and among states foreign
further
this is
our experience
thank you
[Music]
the Ministry of Foreign Affairs of Kenya
um
Madame President excellencies
Madam president Kenya's delegation
commence you and France for the able
stewardship of the security Council
during the month of September
I thank the Secretary General Antonio
Gutierrez and Mr Kareem Khan for their
updates on the situation in the Ukraine
the way in the Ukraine is a serious
breach of the United Nations chapter
the obligation to respect the
territorial Integrity of all member
states will be further undermined should
any action be taken to change the Legal
character of the areas in eastern
Ukraine
we are in a moment of grave danger to
International Peace and security
the escalation of the war
the International Community Field is
underway
there are now clear threats being issued
about the potential deployment of
weapons of mass destruction in the
conflict
on the battlefields civilians are being
subjected to Serious harm in
contravention of the fundamental
international law and human rights
obligations it is a priority of the
utmost agency the national authorities
subject they are soldiers to severe
disciplinary action for any abuses
especially on civilians and captured
combatants
military commanders should surrender
those suspected for such atrocities to
the relevant authorities for prosecution
all the parties including those making
allegations of Human Rights abuses or
all those against whom
the allegations are made should agree to
prompt independent and impartial
investigations even as we just click on
them and call for accountability of War
related violations
we know that the truest protection of
civilians is to stop the war
in this regard Kenya calls for an
immediate cessation of hostilities
active hostilities should be replaced by
a mediated agreement that secures the
sovereignty and territory Integrity of
Ukraine while addressing the security
concerns of all parties and Regional
stakeholders Madam president the
situation in Ukraine is highlighting the
need for serious reforms of the United
Nations security Council
his Excellency Dr William Ruto president
of the Republic of Kenya in his speech
yesterday at the general assembly called
for the democratization of the security
Council if its damage legitimacy is not
to be totally destroyed
our president made the Clarion call that
it was time that the council more
powerfully heeded the voice and place of
Africa through reform of its membership
he welcomed President Joe Biden's
announcement calling for the permanent
and non-permanent membership of the
council to be expanded
if there is a major result the world
needs from Ukraine Beyond peace and
security for the people of Ukraine it is
for such an announcement to lead to real
change
the farmers Villages pastoralists fish
folk Traders and workers of Africa need
their livelihoods protected from the
climate crisis they need the many
serious conflicts on the security
Council agenda solved are not relegated
to the margins because of the Ukraine
who will protect their interests in the
security Council by having the means
from an amended U.N Charter
only permanent membership by the African
States will do
in this regard we call on the entire
permanent membership to commit to fully
embracing reforms it is the only way
the people of the world will consider
this institution legitimate enough to
earn their regard and cooperation Madame
President I conclude by saluting the
individuals institutions and governments
as well as the UN bodies in agencies
that continue to help Elevate the
suffering of those affected by the war
in Ukraine I reaffirm Kenya's respect
for Ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial Integrity within its
internationally recognized border
I thank you for your kind attention
Minister of Foreign Affairs of Ukraine
Madam president
distinguished members of the security
Council
Secretary General guterres prosecutor
Han
I think the French presidency for
keeping the focus of the security
Council on the most pressing threat to
International Peace and Security in this
century
Russia's war of aggression against
Ukraine
right as we speak bodies of innocent
victims are still being exhumed from at
least 445 graves in the recently
liberated city of izum
some are not entire bodies but only
parts of them
like a few pairs of children's legs in
one of the graves
the grief of those
who are close and beloved is yet another
Drop in the Ocean of suffering that
Russia has inflicted upon the people of
Ukraine since seven months and eight
years of its barbaric aggression
many of you may have seen the image of a
dead hand
of a 36 years old Ukrainian Soldier his
name was Sergey Silva
with a yellow and blue bracelet still on
it
I do wear one too just want to show it
to you
many of us do
and Russia should know one thing
it will never be able to kill all of us
and here is why
because on February 24th when Russia
attacked Ukraine from all directions
within the first 24 hours tens of
thousands of ukrainians returned from
abroad to defend their country
and what happened within the first 24
hours after President Putin announced
mobilization
the opposite
thousands of Russians booked
international flights to leave Russia
many flights were sold out within hours
yesterday Putin announced mobilization
but what he really announced before the
whole world was his defeat
you can draft 300 500 000 people
that you will never win this war
today every Ukrainian
is a weapon ready to defend Ukraine and
the principles enshrined in the U.N
Charter
Russia will fail and will Bear full
responsibility for the crime of
aggression and consequent war crimes
crimes against humanity and genocide
yesterday president zielinski made it
clear in his address that Russian
responsibility is a key element to
International Peace and security
Ukrainian law enforcement together with
Partners at the international criminal
court
and countries who support both Ukraine
and the ICC work collectively
to collect evidence of Russian crimes
and hold perpetrators to account
we trust in the international criminal
Court Justice will be served
we owe it not only to thousands of
victims but the future future
Generations in Ukraine and Beyond
there will be no peace without Justice
I emphasize that none of the Russian
crimes in Ukraine would have been
possible without the crime of aggression
against Ukraine committed by Russian
leadership
it cannot go unpunished
and the only feasible way to put
President Putin and his entourage on
trial is to establish a special Tribunal
for the crime of aggression against
Ukraine
I reiterate my call on all states to
back this undertaking for the sake of
the very basic principles of humanity
and the U.N Charter
excellencies
many of you may listen to me right now
with one question in mind
is there a chance for peace
will Ukraine negotiate with Russia in
order to end this war
I want to stay crystal clear
no other nation in the world craves for
peace more than Ukraine
president zielinski was very outspoken
about it yesterday
we have never wanted anything but peace
and stable development
we have never wanted this war and never
chose it
we simply want to live normal life
but it's not enough for Ukraine to want
peace
Russia must prioritize diplomacy over
war in order to give peace a chance
what we see instead is Russian
leadership seeking a military solution
only
distinguished colleagues this chamber
has seen many heated debates since 1945
many crises
but the amount of Lies coming from the
Russian diplomats is quite extraordinary
today we are mostly focusing on crimes
committed by Russian soldiers in Ukraine
but if anyone thinks they are the only
one ready to kill torture rape
cut off genitals
they are wrong
Russian diplomats are directly complicit
because their lies inside these crimes
and cover them up
apparently the only thing in today's
address by Russia
in this torrent of Lies worthy of
reaction is the inappropriate slang used
when mentioning a president of a foreign
country
the president of Ukraine
I also noted today that Russian
diplomats flee almost as aptly as
Russian soldiers
before February 24th Russian diplomats
here at the United Nations had
repeatedly denied plans of a full-scale
invasion of Ukraine
the Russian president himself lied into
the face of European leaders saying he
was not planning to attack
it was days before the invasion
Russia is Shameless
they sit at the chair they occupied in
1991 on dubious legal grounds
armed with Evita right and the feeling
of total impunity
Russians are confident that they can get
away with anything and they are entitled
to do anything they want
they think this seat allows them to
violate borders in a 19th century style
imperialist Conquest
they think it allows them to Shell
nuclear power plants and seize them
they think it allows them to unleash
missile Terror on civilians and critical
infrastructure
they think
it allows them to threaten the world
with the use of nuclear weapons
they must be held accountable for all of
this
the issue of responsibility is Central
to the debate we need to ensure that
behavior like this is punishable
otherwise every force in the world every
evil force in the world will be tempted
to follow in Russia's footsteps
I don't need to remind anyone at this
table how many forces on the planet
would like to question
the borders of their neighbors
if Russia can do this why can't they
today we're talking not only about
Ukraine and Russia
the Global Security crisis we all face
is so much larger
all members of the council must realize
that on February 24th Russia attacked
not only Ukraine
it dealt a deadly blow blow to the very
foundations of the United Nations
Charter
no Nation can feel safe until Russia is
held to account for violating the common
principles agreed by all after the
second World War
Russia does not care for them
but they ran 192 other U.N member states
nations of Asia the Pacific Africa the
Middle East
Latin America and Europe are all
interested in upholding the U.N Charter
today
in Ukraine
is fighting to defend principles of this
Charter
especially the principle of territorial
integrity
Madam president Russia's war of
aggression has plunged the world into a
multifaceted crisis
the consequences of this crime are felt
far beyond Ukraine
once Russian warships blocked Ukrainian
seaports it became clear that Ukrainian
agricultural exports are vital to Global
Food security
Russia has demonstrated that it is ready
to put millions of people across afts
Asia Africa and the Middle East at the
risk of hunger simply to achieve its
imperialistic goals
I take this opportunity to thank U.N
Secretary General Antonio guterres
and turkey for facilitating the Black
Sea grain initiative that allowed
Ukraine to resume Maritime grain experts
this summer
Putin recently lied when he said that
most of the grain has been sent to
European countries in fact two-thirds of
the grain were shipped when to consumers
in Africa the Middle East and Asia
the resumption of Ukrainian exports has
tamed food prices and allowed to ease
the acute food insecurity especially for
those most vulnerable
today the Black Sea grain initiative is
under threat
Russian officials are questioning the
effectiveness of the corridor and might
prepare to block the extension of the
initiative once the agreed 120 days are
over in November
we must not allow Russia to resume its
Hunger Games with the world
I therefore urge All Nations especially
those depending on Ukrainian food
experts to put maximum public and
diplomatic pressure in Moscow demanding
to keep the Black Sea grain Corridor
functioning in November and Beyond we
need to protect the vital grain
initiative together
Ukraine reminds a global food security
guarantor despite our own dire situation
we decided to provide humanitarian Aid
to Ethiopia and Somalia sending them an
additional amount of our grains
Ukraine is interested in increasing
Maritime expert volumes both under the
U.N food program and on market
conditions
while hitting peaceful Ukrainian cities
with missiles Russia uses food and
energy as Weapons against the rest of
the world Putin sends tanks into Ukraine
to kill ukrainians while stealing the
well-being and stability from every
European household with energy blackmail
and playing Hunger Games with Asian
African Middle Eastern families by
threatening the functioning of the grain
corridor we are in the same boat
all of us Europeans
Asians Africans Arab Nations Latin
American states we are in the same boat
and we must confront these threats
together
there is no place for neutrality
I said back in February here at the
United Nations that no Nation will be
able to sit out this crisis created by
Russia it still stands
the best reaction to this crisis
stand with Ukraine to protect the U.N
Charter
Russia likes to talk about the developed
world and the developing world he they
try to drive a wedge between ones and
the others
we in Ukraine do not differentiate
all people deserve a normal life
safety and stability and confidence
but we must stay United to stop Russia's
blackmail
and the war on Humanity it launched
your colleagues the most important
pillar of International Peace and
security is the territorial Integrity of
states
no country is allowed to change
internationally recognized borders by
force
Russia has badly damaged this principle
and now the threat of war is hanging
over everyone's head
to restore International Peace and
security we need urgent and decisive
action
yesterday president zielinski proposed a
peace formula which includes not only
accountability but a mechanism of
security guarantees based on article 51
of the U.N Charter
Ukraine has developed the key of
security compact proposing a modern
multi-layered mechanism of guarantees to
ensure Ukraine's security until the
moment it becomes part of NATO
this document though is much broader
than a tool of guarantee to guarantee
the security of Ukraine only
we see it as a universal mechanism that
can be considered and applied to other
countries and contexts in order to
strengthen Regional and Global Security
architecture
Ukraine keeps working with Partners to
realize the vision of the key of
security compact
this is our added value to International
Peace and security for all UN member
states thank you
Mr foreign
thank you madam president Mr Secretary
General excellencies
let me thank the French presidency for
the opportunity to participate in this
important meeting
the Czech Republic now holds the
rotating EU presidency the EU is the
core promoter of values and principles
of the Yuan Charter
check your host the highest number of
Ukrainian refugees per capita over 400
000 in 10 million country
Russia's Colonial unprovoked and illegal
war of aggression against Ukraine sent
this massive wave of the most vulnerable
population abroad
Russian aggression is perhaps the most
dangerous challenge to Global Peace in
recent decades
today it is about Ukraine tomorrow it
may be another country
in August 1968
it was Czechoslovakia invaded by Moscow
LED troops a Crackdown on the so-called
Prague spring a violent interference in
another country's peaceful life turning
my country into an occupied colony
we are hearing about the hastily
organized Shem referendums in part of
Ukraine
Russia cannot trig the International
Community and still again another
State's territory
Russia's aggressive Colonial policy and
Imperial desires must be rejected for
good
Ukraine refused the slavery and bravely
fights for a multilateral world where
rules protect peace
we are horrified by the atrocities
committed by Russian troops in mariopol
bucha irpin izum and elsewhere
and extremely concerned by the report on
the so-called filtration camps right run
by Russia in Ukraine
hundreds of thousands of Ukraine
citizens have been deported to Russia
including children
there are testimonies of sexual and
gender-based crimes used as a method of
warfare
all must be investigated and
perpetrators must be held accountable
we applaud the Secretary General for
launching the UN fact-finding mission on
events in olanifka
more than 40 States including czechia
referred the situation in Ukraine to the
ICC which opened its investigation into
the situation in Ukraine already in
March we strongly support the ICC
including by seconding a public
prosecutor and by voluntary
contributions
and we call for establishment of a
special International tribunal to
prosecute the crime of aggression
committed by Russia
czechlo raw enforcement agencies have
launched criminal investigation of
certain crimes based on on the principle
of universal jurisdiction
the security Council membersburg Global
responsibility for peace and respect to
international law please Act
we need peace in you crying we need to
restore respect for the U.N Charter and
international law we need to ensure
Justice for victims and to stop impunity
of the perpetrators thank you very much
Affairs of Germany
foreign
Madam president dear colleagues
butcher Mario Paul isium when we talk
about the horrors of the unfolding war
in Ukraine we are not talking about
abstract reports
we are talking about children we are
talking about mothers about brothers
about fathers about Grandparents women
and men whose pain is raw
therefore I urge Russia
this is a war you will not win
so end the war
stop the suffering in Ukraine
stop sending more of your own citizen
into death
stop your shame referendums which are as
unlawful as the war they are supposed to
legislamize
stop the grain war that is driving
hunger across the globe especially in
the south
and stop paralyzing this very body the
United Nations security Council
for many
of you here and for some in the general
assembly
this war might have seen like the
regional War far away
in February 24th
because in many parts of the world
there's too much suffering itself driven
by conflict driven by climate
catastrophe driven by the pandemic and
by hunger
we did hear this we in Germany we could
all so feel you in this understanding
but I think we all feel together now
here in the security Council but also in
the general assembly
that since the last 200 days
what is happening can leave nobody
around the globe untouched
now for 200 days of Russia's brutal war
in Ukraine President Putin's most recent
announcements make it clear Beyond any
doubt
Russia is not conducting a so-called
special operation
Russia is leading a full-fledged war of
aggression with war crimes with torture
with rape even of children
Russia's war is since 200 days is also
increasing the hunger the poverty the
encircuit in the world all around the
globe
and I think this is
a clear sign that the Russian foreign
minister only came in for his own speech
and then spoke for quite some while but
didn't even mention the hunger the
poverty the results all around the world
and today in the streets of moscow's
there are no queues of volunteers
wanting to join the war in Ukraine what
we see instead encourages men women and
even children taking to the streets
because they do not want to be part of
this war against Ukraine and they want
not to be part of the hunger war in the
world these men and women feel what we
all feel regardless of where we heal
from now north south east or west
that all this war brings
is pain death and destruction
today here in this chamber we have to
ask therefore our self if we let a
permanent member of this Council launch
such a war of aggression against this
neighbor what would this mean for the
United Nations for an institution whose
Charter states that I quote all members
shall refrain from the threat of use of
force against the territorial Integrity
or political independence of any state
if the shorter means anything to us we
must not stand idle by but live the
spirit of this of our Charter
not in spite of but particularly because
of one member misuses its special reader
rights in the security Council live up
the spirit of our of this Charter of the
United Nation as it has been lifted by
the U.N and our Turkish Partners who
brokered the grain deal
as it is a world food program which is
also supported by Germany that is
shipping the grain to Yemen into the
Hornet of Africa live up the spirit of
United Nations as the United Nations and
the international criminal court that
collect evidence to ensure that the
perpetrators in this war are held
accountable
live the spirit of the United Nations as
the iea that is working to prevent the
catastrophe at the separicha power plant
and whose efforts are supporting in
talks with all side
lift up the spirit of the United Nation
in contrast to the Russian president
because we are the United Nations from
north to south from east to west no
matter how small no matter how big
thank you madam president
s foreign
[Music]
foreign
thank you thank you madam president
dear ministers
the main reason behind today's meeting
is Russia's decision to attack its
neighbor
a fellow member state of the United
Nations
Russia despite being a permanent member
of a security Council
whose responsibility for International
Peace and security should be even
greater
decided to bridge the most fundamental
principles
of our world order
reinvasion has shown that total
disrespect and disregard for
international
humanitarian law and human rights law
the Russian forces
have committed
horrific atrocities
extra judicial executions of civilians
and forced disappearances
torture
or sexual violence including
against children
unable to crack Ukraine's military
resistance Russia turned to Terror
against civilians as a basic tactics of
its War
each day brings new evidence and
testimonies of Russian crimes committed
in the occupied territories
we are shocked by the discovery of
chambers of torture and mass Graves
containing bodies showing signs of
torture and brutality in newly liberated
resume
with new reports coming is you may
become another symbol of Russia's
barbaric methods
against this diet background Poland
continues to advocate for full
accountability for all the violations
and compensation for the inflicting
damage
we support the investigations by
Ukrainian prosecutors if investigations
initiated by other states
we have been closely cooperating with
the international criminal court
prosecutor's office
we were among the broad group of oec
participating States who twice invoke
the oec Moscow mechanism
we support the work of EU and Human
Rights councils Commission of inquiry
also
we have opened a domestic criminal
investigation into Russia's war of
aggression
this is a crime penalized under polish
law
finally
Poland has helped to establish a joint
investigation team operating within the
EU Agency for for criminal justice
cooperation framework to collect and
preserve evidence of the committed
crimes
we should give you consideration to
several initiatives put forward by Kiev
such as the special Tribunal for crimes
of aggression committed against Ukraine
and the international mechanism to
provide compensation for damage caused
by Russia
let me reaffirm Poland's solidarity with
the people of Ukraine
who have shown remarkable courage
resolve and resilience
they have stood up for their country and
their independence with bravery
and determination
now
it is our turn to stand up for the
principles
the vet protect us all
we must hold Russia accountable for the
invasion and all the crimes committed
in the course of his aggression
thank you madam president
for his statements
[Music]
you should minister
Madam president
you were the statement on behalf of the
Baltic states Estonia Latvia and
Lithuania
the major reason we meet today is that
the permanent member of the security
Council Russia is openly threatening
security and the rules-based global
order the very cause this Council was
created for
just a year ago Russia was sowing lies
and distrust now it is sowing cares and
death
day by day Russia defies the principles
of the United Nations and has already
become a synonym of brutality States run
terrorism and genocide
at this very moment the International
Community cannot and should not turn
away
yesterday we all woke up to one more
Putin's attempt to escalate aggression
by announcing mobilization he now has
waged the war against his own people
against the people who meant to be the
future of the country but are now turned
into the weapons of colonial past
sowing fear blackmailing manipulating
are the very few weapons he has left
with sowing scare is his only tactics
but we shall fear not we shall meet
Putin's desperate Sable rattling with
calm and resolve
condemnation alone will not end these
crimes it is imperative that the
international organizations use all of
their resources to bring Russia's
atrocities to the public light and on
the charge sheets of international
Justice it is our duty to bring Putin to
Justice
the special tribunal to address a crime
of Russia's aggression against Ukraine
must be established thus if
International Organization will stand up
for justice half as strong as Ukraine
stands for the universal values peace
will prevail and justice will prevail
Madam president
Russia's war against Ukraine has
far-reaching consequences Beyond Europe
Ukraine is one of the major exporters of
wheat corn and sunflower oil
that we shall make it very clear the
shortage of food is due to the Russia's
aggression against Ukraine and due to
the blockade of the Ukrainian ports and
not because of internationally imposed
sanctions and this and as if the child
sheet was not full enough the Moscow
regime has now pressed the button of
nuclear threats knowing that we all know
that the consequences of the disaster in
zapore Asia may be potentially worse
than Chernobyl or Fukushima but we shall
fear not we shall use all the power of
International Community to demand from
Russia the unconditional withdrawal of
its military from the parisia Madam
president when we say Ukraine we mean
true courage and unbeatable resilience
Ukraine fights for every principle the
UN stands for Ukraine fights for every
one of us
therefore Madam president I call on this
council do not fear to act fear of your
doubt and indifference I call on every
state we still have a chance to preserve
peace and security by taking right
decisions to defend the rules-based
international order I call on the entire
International Community accountability
matters and Justice cannot be escaped
this is the momentum when we have the
chance to decide in what world we want
to wake up tomorrow
and just before I go I want to remind
that it's not just only Russia that
shall be held accountable the regime of
Belarus shall be on the chart sheet too
slavo Korean I thank you
all right
is foreign
Affairs of Belarus
minister
um
foreign
is
foreign
obviously
[Music]
we never had any problems
all foreign
Association
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
as a country it's a restaurant
contrary to Common Sense thank you
for statement
of the European Union for security
policy and foreign affairs
crucial very important session
it's more than six months now
into these illegal senseless and brutal
War
as it has been said by many here today
this is a frontal attack on the United
Nations Charter
and international rules-based order
it's a chemically pure attack on the
United Nations Charter
let's join our voice to the
international court of justice
that has ruled that Russia must halved
its Invasion immediately
by large majorities the general assembly
has adopted resolutions calling on
Russia to stop its aggression
morally and politically
Russia has already lost the war
and increasingly
it is losing on the battlefield as well
Ukraine will prevail
the whole world has heard presidents put
in latest announcements
and his plan to go ahead
with sham referenda as a Purdue to
Illegal annexation
which will be never recognized
and also his mobilization of 300 000
reservists
and his open nuclear threats
by all that world security is in danger
global leaders meeting at the United
Nations in New York this week
must send a clear and United signal that
the use of weapons of mass destruction
isn't acceptable in any circumstances
I am encouraged by the many statements I
heard here today about this issue
regrettably
President Putin is continuing along the
dangerous path of escalation
he is trying to intimidate Ukraine and
all countries that support Ukraine
but this will fail
it has failed in the past and it will
fail again
as all wars of invasion eventually do
but how many more men women and children
need to die
before the Russian president's decided
to silence his guns
this goes more than I war in Europe
at stake is the protection of weaker
States
from more powerful ones
do we want the global rule of law
or do we want the law of the jungle
do we believe in the spheres of
influence or on their free choice of
sovereign states
this goes a tragedy
in so many ways
in addition to the terrible casualties
and the destruction goals in Ukraine
Russia is dragging the world into an
economic recession and a global food
crisis
as the European Union we do what we can
to counter this Fallout
our support for Global Food security
amount to more than 7.7 billion until
2024.
we support the Black Sea grain
initiative facilitated by the Secretary
General and turkey
together with our European Union's
solidarity Lanes this has helped to
lower Global food crisis but unhappily
not to cancel it
two-thirds of Ukraine grain is sported
this way
goes to those countries that needed must
not to the Europeans
the core issue today is accountability
Russian armed forces have been
terrorizing civilian populations and are
committing countless unspeakable crimes
must murder destruction rape and forth
migration
all victims of Russia aggression deserve
justice and reparation
we have seen the recent images from the
Massachusetts
follow the pattern we saw in busha and
elsewhere
as Russian troops that expelled we
discovered the true horrors of the
occupation
as president zelenski said in the
general assembly yesterday
when they have been crimes there must be
justice otherwise peace will not be
possible
we will do whatever it takes to ensure
accountability
rely on international criminal court and
on the Ukrainian authorities we are
supporting the ICC financially and
technically on assisting the office of
the Ukrainian prosecutor General by
providing training expertise and
equipment
including uncollective evidence
Madam president
ensuring accountability
is the responsibility of all of us
we owe this not only to the victims
but also to the Next Generation to the
future of Ukraine
because fighting impunity today will
contribute to a more secure and just
future for all
thank you
for
[Music]
a statement
s
described on the list of speakers
the meeting is adjourned
thank you